fake we're on Ron okay we're back this
is date fails this is technically a new
episode even though we just had Dahmer
overlap cages yatta maze I quit the show
oh yeah it was a tease Erik gives away
personal information about me on the
show that I wouldn't necessarily give
away I'm I don't have plans tonight I'm
wide open available they really do you
aren't seriously your brain it's crazy
because I see this actually about this
guy and it's true for you like Dom you
spit jokes out like it's breathing
like I mean jokes come out of his mouth
like we just worked a week together in
Vegas every hour there's like three
funny jokes
doesn't sound like a lot but that's a
[ __ ] lot like that's a lot of jokes
that's why he's a freakin legend you're
like 24 hours a day
what are you number number five on the
top 100 number 80
I was the number 79 and Tampa side
splitters thought I was 71 so they got
all they wanted to surprise me and they
they got all the girls a little girls at
work their t-shirts yeah I rarer 71 are
you serious yeah and then I went I'm not
71 at 79 you think oh you're 71 now yeah
it's so funny that they had t-shirts
made though it was probably his salary
number 71 that's hilarious number 71
that is so amazing but you are yourself
when he had so much fun with you in
Vegas that was great yeah we are we but
we went golfing whoo you're a good
golfer you been golfing
whoa what are you sure we went wasn't
real golf tell about played metrics are
hard to explain it's like this is the
first of all it is just giant field in
front of you that goes out like a
thousand yards I guess I don't know what
it was but yeah and if you can get one a
ball and
oh god this is good comedy huh a-hole
you win yeah well you get points right
we were all you know most of us didn't
golf and we get up there and a lot of us
Wang and just missed everything which I
thought was funny yeah couple times it
dribbled off the side amazed where
people don't get hurt and it's basically
kind of like pictures I got driving just
standing on the edge of a building like
you know in the movies how you'll see
like people hitting balls off like
skyscrapers right you're kind of like on
the side of a building and you're
hitting the balls out and there's this
huge field with a bunch of huge holes in
it and if you hit the ball into a hole
you get points but it's all kind of like
done electronically it's all scored
electronically Oh neat but the thing is
there's people drinking and there's
pools inside and there's girls in
bikinis and it just seems like a recipe
for someone to get like hit in the head
with a girl yeah absolutely but we went
there we're in Vegas is it it's so damn
GM right across the street yeah Harry
Basil's wife kept talking about cheap it
was I'm thinking it's cheap because you
didn't have to pay not that it was $40
or $50 for an hour yeah but the whole
thing cost it was it was like it was
$150 gift certificate from Mexico nice
daughter yeah so the whole thing had to
be like four or five hundred dollars was
it really oh I think it was like 250 I
think the bill was like - oh right but
after the gift you're right that was
like 400 bucks I think Wow but we bought
a lot of drinks drink for dogs got me
drunk in Vegas you got me drunk at the
bar don't act all innocent I did I got
too drunk I don't trick respectfully tom
is the most I just see me throwing a
move on Kate and the Kate going what's
wrong just gives me Dom just gives me a
dating advice it's great I'm more
paternal that's how sad it is now dad I
go it go out cuz I care about her thank
you
it's not like an
because you hit on girls I mean what's a
youngest girl you've dated what's the
biggest age gap you've ever had dating
here or Thailand
we don't need to talk about that well
what's the biggest age gap I mean like I
for me it was 50 like I'm 34 now I dated
a guy who was 50 to 50 years no 52 is
the oldest I don't know I mean I don't
really ask the ages I don't know me yes
you do
you don't know I asked a girl her age
you don't ask them their age I don't
know what do I care I'm a another 18 how
do you know by the lines of no I can't
tell anywhere how old people are
sometimes I meet people that I think
okay like I I like football players you
know kidding they all look like they're
35 but a lot of them are like twenty-two
it turned out yeah so I'm saying you
can't tell by looking something you you
compares for 22 Oh dawn no I and now I'm
I flirt with you now no I thought it's
very sweet of you
well it's a lot of Botox that's right uh
I could pass for like 19 yeah no I said
that if I had Down syndrome I could [ __ ]
anyone I wanted and no one would hold it
against me
case having a surgery done to make me
feel really guilty because he's like
Davis personalities [ __ ] happy
ecstatic okay first of all there's so
much I want to talk about with you
I don't even I want to talk about go
ahead let's start with gerbils let's
start with gerbils let's start with this
I have you did you know that Dom has
been
and not only two episodes of Golden
Girls he was also an episode of Seinfeld
and my favorite movie ever The Big
Lebowski did you know that yes of course
you did the episode of Seinfeld where
you had the fire the fire or Jason
Alexander keeps punking out and Jon
farboro is the clown I liked the clown
actually that's right that's right I'm
so funny because he says the Jason Jason
goes how could you not know bozo yeah he
goes listen man it's just a game let it
go because I'm sure bozo was a big plan
in the 60s how did you like want to act
when you started doing stand-up you
start acting first thought I was acting
way before standing oh you are yeah I
was in college I was lucky because I
went to a school was all-girls for for
drama you know I was in a it was in
Catholic colleges and they were both but
basically the same-sex college you know
there was boys or you know the girls
would work they could run a consortium
with them so they could but whatever
subjects they didn't have that could
come over here so wait you went to an
all-girls school for your drama class
just drama like it wasn't like Lily just
you were the only guy no there were like
three or four of us but the great genius
great thing was Satine I only played I
didn't plan on going into drama a friend
of mine as a priest you know said to me
he should go into drama he knows he
appeals to my laziness he knows me well
enough and I go along I don't really you
know do plays and stuff he goes yeah
there's no term paper
what do you mean again they have like a
recital no turntable and that's what got
me into it wasn't any love of theater
right right no way but then because it
was so few guys we got really good parts
yeah we got and if I was at Northwestern
I probably wouldn't be in one play there
was in a play you know where was this
Miami Miami Shores very wise you went to
school in Miami yes that's why I'm a
Dolphins fan oh it all makes sense now
cuz when he showed up in Vegas wearing
dolphins you were on a dolphin shirt and
I was confused me and Tosh tie got that
Tosh gave me all that stuff all that all
that swag he gave it to you yeah went
over and did his show one day and he had
like everything set up for me it's so
funny I was with him last night
they said to me how you mean house we're
drinking and it's so nice to have
somebody care about you you know you
everybody thinks it's dosh this wiseass
guy yeah right and I lied to him you did
yeah I said you know I've been just
drinking one a day yeah is he sober yeah
oh I didn't know that yeah I I drank a
lot in Vegas more than usual but I don't
drink that much that's for one night I
know that's a lot for me I mean that
drunk you just say that you're drunk
yeah well I seen you really bad I think
I get just happier and happier yeah yeah
she's nice you have a drunk I'm happy to
worry about her like turning [ __ ] or
emotional scenes but I send a lot of
nudes that's my hang-up really yeah when
I get drunk if I'm where do you see her
in the bathing suit you ever get to see
we should talk I'm in with Kay I'm a
room oh yeah did you know I moved Erica
in with me he's living in my kitchen I
live in our kitchen in my actual kitchen
I'm such a [ __ ] I'm like he's like can
I just sleep on your couch I'm like no
you can't have my living room I use it
you can have my kitchen you can sleep in
the kitchen what do you sleep on I got I
sleep in the other in the freezer
seriously we got a futon wait she got
like a living little dining-room area
yeah he's sleeping on a futon but just
very quickly have you ever heard of
putting your clothes in the freezer to
wash them no you put your jeans in the
freezer and it gets rid of the debris
and I wait they don't get faded what do
you feel like he comes in my living room
goes Kate you mind if I put my dirty
jeans in your freezer they're not even
dirty I grabbed him two days ago
I go why he goes they're skinny jeans
you can't wash them or this shrink you
just stick them in the freezer and they
come clean but you're wasting 2730 I
mean you've been walking around in those
jeans for two days in the LA Heat you're
gonna stick them in the freezer with
your ball sweat on them and you call
that clean boy there's nothing
freezer so I can put them right on the
top of the pile is two key stay out of
my freezer I think there's a little
magic going on between you two no
there's there's no magic magic if
anything we're gonna kill each other to
kill her
no Eric and I are like brother sister
there's no there's never been any sexual
tension between us never right
it's really weird actually I think a lot
of that might come from your lack of
ampere I told him that he has to put a
room divider between the kitchen and the
living room so I can't walk in on him
having sex or jerking off wait that's
the only way you don't don't worry about
everybody having sex with me it's hard
to get women to come in the kitchen yeah
but not for a long time I mean I lived
with women yeah more like a marriage
we've been married three how many times
one time but really four times you know
like as far as living with somebody what
how old were you the first time we got
married well the first time I live with
somebody was in college
oh the first girl you loved with yeah it
was a bad idea because that was the days
of no aids one person because you know
you could [ __ ] everyone yeah there are
other STDs gonorrhea yeah but they were
baby stuff compared to AIDS when were
you in college uh early 70s so we're
condoms even around I haven't done
research on the history of condoms
maybe I should maybe before yes those
kind of questions all right so there
were condoms then I think we've
established
people actually use them though because
what I'm saying it's like now I feel
like no one uses them Franks I'm telling
do you have condoms next year bad no
next of the bed well where do you keep
myself vending machine in his living
room
okay so wait let's go back to the first
the first girl you lived with was in
college how long were you guys together
two and a half years okay and then I
lived with why the one who I eventually
married and then I live with another one
for with ten years and then the so that
was my whole adult life pretty much
you're kind of like a serial monogamist
really did you ever have periods where
you were like him like a bachelor like
out there playing the field for a while
yeah doing lots of dating well no not
dating as much as just sex
yeah no because I was a doorman at a bar
which bar place called doc Watson's in
Philly yeah yeah yeah you know I carted
the girls so I could you know I could
easily pick them up while as they were
coming in you know checking their fake
ID right right I was with this one girl
one time and that she claimed she was a
model and she was really hot she looked
like a model she look like a dancer
right no but she didn't look fashion
model but I like that better anyway like
a stripper yeah but she wasn't act but
anyway she she said we were starting to
have sex and we had sex the first night
and then after that we had there wasn't
her girlfriend was gonna sleep on the
couch and I thought oh this is great you
know I think Oh Liz that is gross
beautiful and my girlfriend's beautiful
she's do you mind if she sleeps with us
I said you know I don't whine I'm
thinking this doesn't really happen does
it this is like penthouse stories you
know and so the girls in bed so my
girlfriend's like combing her hair some
so her me and her start making out yeah
and then we're breaking it and oh my
girlfriend gets in bed and I'm thinking
you know show more attention to the new
girl
that's to make her feel warm you know
what happened right she yeah she got
pissed but [ __ ] it then if you're just
gonna [ __ ] her and they don't know what
can I said you're the one that asked her
and I wouldn't say hmmm we bring her in
bed with us you were the one who started
and you know you talk about blue balls
I was so [ __ ] this is when we know no
[ __ ] that it was painful yeah I
couldn't wait till I hit a light on my
way home so I could come but like a
[ __ ] machine gun and not for free
yeah oh you paid for them yeah so then
you can do whatever you want
well yeah because you know I like when
they you know take care of each other
and I just slide on the floor on the wet
goop slide on the floor I always
wondered like well okay it's so funny
that you brought this up because I was
actually gonna bring it up but I was
kind of embarrassed to talk about it
with you which I don't know why cuz I
told you to come in the eyes story and
everything but like when we were in
Vegas the last night that we were there
no no I know I didn't this couple came
to see me and they were both really hot
I met the girl before but I'd never met
the guy the guy was SuperDuper hot and
they were like really flirty with me and
stuff but then they went home they
didn't invite me over but then a couple
days later they were here in LA for work
Oh
and they hit me up what was it work
pornography something in that world
adult entertainment yeah oh it doesn't
matter that I came in for adult
entertainment where grown men can jerk
off like little monkeys the point is
they invited me and like they were
really really like super super wanting
me to come over for a threesome but the
thing is the girl I told him I go here's
the thing I'm not into [ __ ] like I
could maybe do the threesome I'm not
going to be into like going down
on her or anything so it might not be
let her go down on you yeah that's so
sweet
but so they actually got I had a show in
Long Beach and they actually rented a
room in Long Beach hoping I would call
okay I was no I was at heart bells
I was just great actually really it was
a great actually talked about this a
little bit on stage yeah but so I I
wasn't feeling great so I bailed but
also I felt notionally or physically
physically but also I felt I know I was
I think I was still hung over from Vegas
to be really honest I was kind of sick
for a day oh yeah you sucked like eleven
yes like eleven hours really burnt and
we burnt the but here's the thing the I
think I could do it and I kind of wanted
to but I don't think I can like just
show up at the hotel room like a pizza
that's being delivered right think it
has to happen organically for me to want
to do ordered the Cape you know what I
mean cuz then if I just show up like
does that make me like that kind of
makes me just like a hooker for free no
it's just a [ __ ] it's not a hooker no
but I mean that's what it would be
classify that what defines a slight you
think do you believe that really DOM is
a Christian pod can you have an opinion
on girls that like have lots of sex
yeah I think it's you know sounds like
fun you think I mean like the web
immoral stand on it yeah like do you
think that it you know how I am with you
all I care about is your health
I know not your morals yes have no
morals I do too I really do
I'm like Dexter I am dirty but I have a
code I'm dark but I have a code that's
how I feel
where do you draw the line um I won't
sleep with someone that I know has a
girlfriend or wife ever and actually you
know I don't hook up a lot I don't know
cup with randoms I don't want to get a
disease yeah I know that's what I worry
about
that's why we've had this discussion I
know because you think Dom thinks that
hooking up with porn stars is is really
dangerous but I feel like they're
cleaner I can't be cleaner cleaner than
what can't be clearer than somebody who
didn't just [ __ ] three girls I feel like
they're cleaner than maybe like Anders
or famous actors or people that get lots
and lots because I get tested on a
regular basis I don't buy the testing
thing Kate I told you here's what
happens the guy goes gets tested and
from testing he goes right to a girl who
has some disease and he [ __ ] her so
he's a tested to clean but you're not
gonna know and then sometimes won't show
up for a couple it can be dormant and
you really put too much faith in the
testing thing you're right all right
well it's done anyway I want to talk
about about like how was your day well I
had six dicks in my face like I don't
ask those questions did it bother you
though and when you started liking them
yeah I mean that's the reason why like a
human element in this yeah I can't date
him that I can't I can't date I can't
I thought that I could but you know what
it's not actually about the sleeping
with other people things somehow it's
weird it doesn't bother me when it's
work but it's more about the lack of sex
that I would get in the relationship Wow
I don't think you're gonna turn it that
way we're talking about that about the
idea you only have so much jizz but no
matter how old you want though what's
the most guy can come four or five times
the most today according to Jim six or
seven times Jim Jefferies said he jerks
off six seven times a day when he's
alone in a hotel room can you do me a
favor yeah change the subject I gotta
get that out of my head
with his Australian accent you're gonna
be no worry I mean I don't know do you
think four times a day for time okay I
can't believe you this was something so
rude have some dignity and there's my
god it is weird because I think of Dom
like I really do think of you I don't
think of you like a father but I think
of you like family almost so it is weird
like it's hard for me to ask you like
the questions that I would normally want
to ask someone it's hard for me to ask
Tom Eric you're gonna have to ask him
the dirty questions look I'm turning red
I'm not a dirty person
when did you lose your virginity I was
late actually really like this year
college Oh his college girlfriend was
like just like a hookup uh well she was
in a play with me okay she was little
she played with them all right I do I do
was it one just once no okay so you were
seeing her she was the overlap to the
other one but there were a few college
girls it was I mean it's really easy in
those days I remember waking up on a
Saturday and going that was really fun
what's your name
really yeah Jim said it was easy and
Britain news I missed the more I think
that it's just somehow well why do you
think it was easier back then because
because the STD thing people didn't do
one time there was a crab's epidemic in
our school so these [ __ ] retards went
out and got real bushels of crabs and
threw them all and they were you know
crawling up the hall like a monster
movie you hear the maid scream in there
oh my god there's nothing rid of the
crabs we had it all it was uh we had to
use a special shampoo all over our body
because I'm in the actual shampoo huh
like lice but I don't know yeah you
already use it and then yeah they must
Addie fumigated the school or something
right yeah probably
it was just outside I have like a list
of questions that people sent in so I'm
gonna ask you a whole bunch of these
questions okay all right you two what's
the longest you've ever gone without
having sex you mean does that include
jerking off month a month really well
yeah after like after I broke up I was
with my girlfriend that I loved the most
left and we had to break up because I
didn't want to get married I was too
depressed I didn't want yeah you know
why didn't you want to get married
[ __ ] comedian I don't know it kind of
sucks being married well yeah we were
married at 20 in your heart
I wasn't hot thank you I wasn't hot
though and I didn't really get hot ish
until 25 what uh I was I was ugly
teenager and I just didn't really learn
you know what it is it's LA I didn't get
hot till I moved to LA I was a little
thicker so you know you I would think
it'd be just the opposite because
there's so much competition here that
somebody told me the other night that
I'm not really their buddy talk they
were talking about themselves I'm not
really hot for LA well yeah I'm not hot
for LA but I'm just saying I wasn't hot
or I wasn't even considered hot by
anyone's standards so I moved on maybe
you didn't have the confidence you have
now well I didn't have the tits that's a
start
your tits are not real you didn't know
that I think you told me but I know a
good job because they don't look they
look I won small thank you do you have
any work done
I'm eyeballs died last week yeah I heard
beautiful accentuate your take I was
blessed with a great team did you know
that DOM opened on the road for cher
cher gonna teen yeah taint reminder for
years yeah yeah I want to talk about
this so how long did you open for her
well from 1990 we did the tour they'd
like a tour of Canada and North America
tour in Canada the US and then we
started doing casinos and probably
another five years of the sands in
Atlantic City and the Mirage we I was
the first one on stage
that wasn't Siegfried and Roy the very
first one advantage at the Mirage
serious yeah no no and then after we
stopped we you know we cut Vegas out
then I didn't see her for a few years
and then when she was on her farewell
tour Cyndi Lauper was got hurt she was
opening for her in Texas the good thing
about being a comedian you don't have a
band you don't have a little you know
you have dry clean shirts and clean
underwear and that's it so I was there
the next day and went back and they gave
me a credible raise you know they were
good to me but I was like drinking a lot
and I kind of [ __ ] it up but oh really
yeah but how did that even start how did
you meet her how did you get that gig in
the first place she she saw me at The
Improv I think she saw me on television
first and then she came in to see me and
there was a she had a little gay manager
it was a [ __ ] great guy named Billy
Sabbath and he liked this guy Bobby
Collins Bobby because Bobby's like I
can't like a lot handsomer than me and
another dumb answer but you know he he
liked him and sure liked me
because you know she's like my humor and
and the guy it's funny how he gets stuff
you never know how you get it there
wasn't even about the comedy they said
my manager said to them well you know
who would you rather hang out with
Tour d'amour Bobby cones and they go
well Dom it was well and they go you're
right we booked him I mean sure I was
sure was gonna win anyway but horse
no it's her gig that's so amazing
you're like like it's funny because I
one night when we were at the Laugh
Factory
not this time the last time there was a
show was that rock and roll show called
that was playing at the Trop roll yeah a
show called The Rock vault at the
tropics and this show was basically like
it was basically like a bunch of famous
musicians playing news isn't one on the
road at the time obviously Jovi can't
think of Dave's name they're from their
White's a dear friend no he's what he
was it already oh we could play [ __ ]
the Torah yeah yeah but we're sitting so
those guys are playing in this show baby
mater David mater yeah that's his name
oh you went to the show we went down
they canceled that show is so [ __ ]
gay it was such a good show but we went
down between between Laugh Factory shows
and we watched some of their show yeah
afterwards they came upstairs and the
green room behind the Laugh Factory they
do karaoke sometimes on Saturday nights
so these guys are in there Dom's in
there who else came there were some
other comics that came that night yeah
you didn't see cookie George sing did
you know oh god he's good oh yeah yeah
because he wasn't there that night but I
you know I played that I was I was
looking up something free about you
trying to find some information and that
was on you know Donna oh that's so funny
so plain to hear you know like I had
never really listened to it because I
saw your girlfriend that we had dinner
with member was Valentine's Day yeah we
had dinner on Valentine's Day we were in
Vegas on Valentine's Day with DOM and I
working a lot factory also that's
but it was crazy because we're sitting
in the green room and just listening to
you guys
trade Road stories oh yeah do you ever
just sit and like does it ever occur to
you how kind of you've been around all
these iconic people do you ever even
think about it like your life is kind of
amazing you know when it's you you don't
really think about it I mean there are
times like I'll give you an example you
know for like as far as name-dropping
and friends and stuff this is pretty
funny looking back Bruce Willis has been
a friend of mine since he was a
bartender and I love Bruce and I know
he's got you know you know some people
have problems with him some people are
crazy about him whatever just like all
of us but he invites me over to see it
to watch Monday Night Football this was
in New York and I was doing a comedy
club and he said much covert I said well
you know where he was at this place
called the San Marcos I believe I
believe they sold it now they're called
mansions in the sky right and to me was
showing me the the book of these
mansions there anyway bruce says to come
over and i said to him it's innocently
but ignorantly I go what apartment Lee
and like he's in an apartment like he's
in for being rude to me and he want to
be a jerk so he says you know what just
you know I'll come down and pick you up
I'll come down the elevator pick you up
like what apartment yeah so we go we go
up to his mansion in the sky and was
incredible and you know you forget that
you know what I mean yeah where was he a
bartender at a place called the I think
was it called the central the center he
was brought in a couple places but you
know I hear something funny about him
and I don't to get off your subjects too
much I don't care at all he we had I was
starting to get work as a comedian and I
was in an improv group there was very
good group called the Broadway local
Michael Patrick King the producer he was
in it my ex-wife Lisa Mandy was in it
yeah and we were really good really good
good voices and just and I had think I
was starting to get stand-up work so I
said lunch you know we had an audition a
couple people and of course you know
what's going to happen I said well I got
this friend Bruce Willis he's really
[ __ ] good good-looking guys funny
talented and they
they brought him in they brought in a
couple other people and maybe wanted to
and they pushed didn't get the part
he's a [ __ ] movie star you know yeah
I heard what was his big break
moonlighting yeah yeah but for that one
he got that it was it was brilliant in
it yeah that was the oath of the
beginning of the one camera shows that I
remember right I loved the way it was
shot yeah do you have a favorite project
that you've ever worked on uh well I
mean that project so much as like
favorite moments you know like when I
was on stage and I headlined at the what
happened was when I was opening for
Whitney Houston this was at the this is
at the sands and she she wasn't really
nice you know like I mean she was like I
shared our own problems I guess coke and
whatever I didn't know him her Bobby
Brown you know she would have all these
bounces around her and they'd say a
prayer and I'm thinking I don't think
Jesus had bouncers you know and anyway
the guy asked me he was gonna let me
headline the first for the first time in
a casino and he says listen I'd like to
bring you in on this weekend we're
Whitney's and then she can't do the last
show can you do it you can you know
start headlining and I said and that was
pretty thrilling you know yeah and it
was also funny because I imitated her
and talked about you know yeah yeah I
really think they're fun goofy is
singing you know but I felt so bad for
her father because he was such a nice
guy and he says you want you know I
really like your work I really like you
to work with my daughter it some more
and all I said was thank you I'm
thinking there's no [ __ ] way I'd
rather be it's slappy bananas the rest
of my life really
Wow for some cool people like Natalie
Cole yeah it was the best best singer I
ever opened for but yeah sure is a great
singer but I love shows voice a lot of
people don't but Natalie Cole was
[ __ ] awesome that's so interesting
that you've opened for so many musicians
I didn't realize that it doesn't seem
like a lot of comics do that anymore
yeah that was big back in the day with
this well Cheryl was very different
because she was such an icon and she was
so you know moonlight
moonstruck and you know all the like the
Academy Awards right you know just she
did send that Sonny and Cher show so
this was her audience would be like
transvestites that you know they look
like her and a little girl with her
grandmother yeah so it was a really very
so yeah it's cool how much time did you
24 you went out and did 25 calls yeah
the only time I was really nervous was
at Madison Square Garden
Oh because my sister made me nervous
because my sister goes I can't believe
you're gonna call these people
oh my god it's Madison Square Garden and
I'm thinking oh [ __ ] Lord oh please
don't do this you know I said I tried to
get away from and she didn't mean
anything she's my sister you know and
that was kind of nerve-wracking was
funny because the next night we're at
the Pepsi Center in we did two minutes
Square Garden shows next door at the
Pepsi Center in Denver and I thought
what a relief you know even though it
was like twenty three twenty three
thousand people it was more than the
garden but I thought why it's so nice to
be without all that pressure because
when I was up on stage I never do this
to myself
I never double-sink I'm kind of there at
the moment but I'm thinking [ __ ]
Sinatra played here
yeah John Lennon was here the Molly
ali-frazier fights were here this is the
[ __ ] garden not to psych yourself out
yeah don't look up I was like don't be
so nervous
I was not you know I'm not like I was
when I did this Tonight Show
not even close yeah that was terrible
when was your first Tonight Show 1942
okay well I mean were you I was when I
did your show so Dom just taped this
special in Las Vegas when we were there
oh you dick yeah we're special he did so
[ __ ] great the crowds were great so
great but so he asked me to bring him on
in a bikini that's why I had the high
heels and high heels
it's like normally you know me when I do
the bikini thing I usually wear like
ugly shoes on Pearl yes good taste well
I was so nervous that can be slowly you
were nervous I was so nervous I can be
scary because it's so much heart well I
think in my head
bring him up her - all set I did my set
what did five minutes five minutes I did
five minutes and then I've had a go it
actually went great it was a great idea
I think not because it was one idea but
I loved it I should look so beautiful
and I asked her was not to comment on it
yeah he said that was why I was nervous
by the way because originally he told me
he asked me to do it on my kill whatever
you want and I'm thinking in my head
I'll go out and make jokes like oh I
really wanted to be a part of Dom's
special and this is what he made me wear
but then he was like oh I think it'd be
funnier if you don't mention it yeah
Jimmy H was actually funny huh because
the only thing I said the only reference
I would owe is I came out and I just
said it's really hot backstage man it's
really hot backstage I just did regular
material that was it maybe that's how
can I sell you an Ontario improv way in
the beginning my great you kill some in
some ways I do it frees me up and I'm
almost more like I just have such a
[ __ ] attitude because once I'm out
there and that it's like well they're
gonna love me or hate me so what can I
do at this point it almost it's like you
know I did stand-up naked the Playboy
channel was really not on TV my that's
how I got my TV show I wrote to them and
was like I'm a comedian you should do a
spread on me
unlike sexy funny comedians and well
when I came in they were like are you
willing to do a test shoot while you're
here and get naked and I was like I have
to do that I didn't know that was part
of the part of the process but I guess
since I'm at Playboy you know how that
you know people always tell you like
when they ask you anything in an
audition just say yes like can you ride
a horse sure like whatever they want so
I was like sure whatever so I got naked
I took photos they're so bad I've seen
him I was so uncomfortable because I
hate trying to be sexy but then while I
was still naked they were like what's
your stand-up like let's hear some of
your act so I started doing material in
front of like 12 playboy executives -
that's how I got the job yeah I forgot I
was naked once I started talking that's
fun got the tonight so don't be so
everyone gets gigs in this town right
isn't that what house carry well I got
The Tonight Show how I was a very
interesting I never auditioned for it
what happened was I was I was a
late-night er at The Improv I just moved
down here yeah they gave me a couple
good spots but basically I was a
late-night her but the waitresses like
me yeah like my act and the waitresses
I'm in the guy named Jim McAuley he
loved those waitresses we were [ __ ]
beautiful girls and they brought him in
unbeknownst to me and he said anyone he
saw my act and he goes would you like to
do tonight's show I go yeah you're
kidding he goes well you got it serious
yeah that was hell easy it was I go but
I said well what's don't you want to see
a set and he goes I just saw it you
don't need to do anything different Wow
and you know imagine like talk about no
pressure I was the best way right yeah
well and how long like when how how far
how long was it till you taped it like a
couple weeks about 10 years 10 years
not that it's even remotely the same
thing at all but that's how I got the
AVN Awards is that this show time people
came to see me at Ventura Harbor Club
and they didn't tell me they were coming
oh cool there was no pressure so I
didn't even know that's on Showtime
maybe in yeah yeah but tonight shows a
little bit I got my job at Burger King
yeah I saw Mel Muhammad talking about
you got something you make onion rings
and I said yes all right look I don't
want to keep you for too long because I
had you on part of Jim's episode also in
you I know you have a lot of napping by
the way the text you sent me was late
sends me a text message that says hey
ask me really good questions on your
podcast cuz you're interrupting my day
of eating and napping oh my god
and I was like [ __ ] what am I going to
ask you gotta get up there got another
feeding I can't understand how I'm
gaining weight by eating and going to
sleep what's your favorite restaurant in
Hollywood like I like I like the pizza
at the rainbow I don't know if you're
such a weirdo I'm such a favorite
restaurant in Hollywood is the rain it
smells like puke I would say katana
katanas yeah
is that just good it's next the Comedy
Store or is that because the food's
about well it's combination of it's next
to the economy store it's a lot of my
good friends work there oh really
uh that's right you didn't come out with
us when we went to dinner
I was with Nicole the other than
we went to dinner and my friends were
there oh she's here now it no no we were
we went to Wolfgang's at Caesars Hey
yeah that was good but I think katana or
everything included and they have the
hottest girls with they're so hot that
like you know the how Hollywood is so
ridiculous yeah well we're in Jones
which Jones is one of my favorite like
Loretta deliveries and from my eighties
one of the managers there where Jones
and and I remember my friend Ali who was
musical director for sure it's all ties
together he goes boy she's hot that I
flooded that flat that waitress and I
said yeah they looked at each other but
went but not katana it is crazy in LA
how like the waitresses look like
Victoria's Secret models like this town
is theirs so just hired for their looks
there's nothing they don't even have to
be a waitress it's Japanese yeah you
know it's the fusion is that Roboto
grill you can go there and have chicken
wings and mashed potatoes they sound
like they I'm doing a commercial for
them this episode is brought to you by
katana I'm starving yeah before I let
you go I ask everyone this but do you
have like a worst date or a sex story
that you can remember like or something
crazy anything well one time I was it
was winter and we were down to Jersey
Shore and I was in bed with this girl
and I kept taking clothes off me
but she still had a coat on right
why were you stripping I don't know I
thought we were both do it but I was
guests and my friend knocks on the door
he goes and I had like a [ __ ] big
boner and my friend I was do I go Dan
what's up because Nick you know I had
underwears though so you just had
underwear on yeah
I think it was my place it was like a
Jersey Shore that's pretty that's pretty
bad job I feel like this episode is like
Dahmer king of blue balls like you had
the threesome that went wrong the chick
with the winter coat that took off I
feel that's pretty good I got this girl
coming out from Austin next week and I
never I never slept with her on the
cruise I was on the cruise with the
Impractical Jokers guys yeah you're
talking about that anyway yeah she's
coming out and I said to her she wants
to stay with me
and I said well how about two days and
we'll see how it goes you know because I
don't want to commit to like four or
five days you know but anyway she cause
she's into women it was cool it's cool
he's a good sleepy woman I've never
heard any guy be like she's into women
which sucks when you said that before
it's so funny because when you said the
thing about you know I let the girl get
down on me but I won't go down but like
you know it's so different for guys cuz
I wouldn't let a guy blow me I know it's
so different for guys
I mean even now you tell me like a
massage I didn't say come on your face
okay later
oh god darling what a way to end it I
know that's a perfect ending the image
of that
dude I love you so much thank you for
doing the show see you tonight
yeah you'll see me - is there anything
you want to plug this comes out next
Friday oh you comes out next Friday yeah
oh well great show this week thank you
well it's live streaming now so if
you're watching you can cover the
Hollywood live Factor tonight DOM and I
will be just my twitter and and my
Instagram Twitter it you'll see it on
mine I'm gonna tweet this [ __ ] out
[ __ ]
September 11th I'll be at the Hollywood
improv my cartoon comes out premiere
party my cartoon
it's got court order it's cartoon about
people in rehab yeah it's very fun that
comes out it's a promo pilot I made it
come - and we're doing a premiere
premiere party September 11 7:30 p.m.
Hollywood everyone yes comes that ball
Eric at Eric Myers comedy at Dahmer era
at all things comedy and I'm Kate
Quigley at Kate cue funny bye everybody
okay thanks her dude of course thank you